DAN: YOU PROBABLY SAW THE VIRAL
PHOTO OF THE COAL MINER AT THE
KENTUCKY BASKETBALL GAME.
HE WANTED TO BRING THIS SON TO
THE GAME.
HE PROMISED.
HE PROBABLY JUST LEFT WORK.
HE HAD COAL DUST ON HIS FACE.
I GREW UP IN A BLUE COLLAR
HOUSEHOLD.
MY FATHER WAS A BLUMER AND MY
BROTHER AN ELECTRICIAN.
WE HAVE AN ELECTION COMING UP.
THOSE BLUE COLLAR WORKERS WORK
THEIR ASSES OFF.
I REMEMBER GOING INTO A RADIO
STATION TO DO A MORNING SHOW.
IT WAS ABOUT 2:30, 3 IN THE
MORNING.
I SAW TRUCKS ON THE SIDE OF THE
ROAD SLEEPING IN THEIR CABS.
WE SEE THIS STUFF IN WALMART AND
THE SUPERMARKET, AND YOU THINK
IT JUST MAGICALLY GOT THERE
SOMETIMES.
YOU WANT TO BUY A BOUGHT OF COKE
OR PEPSI?
LOOK AT THAT.
IT MAGICALLY ARRIVED ON THE
SHELF.
SOMEONE CREATED THAT.
SOMEONE'S FINGERS GOT DIRTY TO
CREATE IT.
THANKS TO BLUE COLLAR AMERICA.
YOU HAVE GOT A VOTE COMING IN
THIS ELECTION.
JOINING ME.
HOST OF "HOW AMERICA WORKS" ON
FOX BUSINESS.
MIKE ROWE.
LAWYERS ARE GREAT, ACCOUNTANT
ARE FANTASTIC.
BUT YOU NEED HVAC WORKERS AND
ELECTRICIANS.
>> THERE ARE TWO SIDES OF A
COIN.
WE DO THIS ALL THE TIME.
WE ELEVATE ONE FORM OF EDUCATION
AT THE EXPENSE OF THE OTHERS.
WE ELEVATE ONE CATEGORY OF JOBS
AT THE EXPENSE OF THE OTHER
CATEGORY OF JOBS.
WE JUST CAN'T SEEM TO SET THE
TABLE FAIRLY.
WE HAVE GOT TO HAVE OUR THUMB ON
THE SCALE.
THAT PICTURE YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT, I SAW IT A COUPLE DAYS
AGO.
I BEGAN TO SIT DOWN AND WRITE
SOMETHING.
BUT BEFORE I COULD, PEOPLE SENT
TO IT ME AND SAID HAVE YOU SEEN
THIS?
WHAT IS IT ABOUT THE IMAGE THAT
MATTERS?
WHAT MATTERS TO ME IS WE HAVE
KIND OF FORGOTTEN WHAT WORK
LOOKS LIKE, AND WE HAVE KIND OF
FORGOTTEN WHAT FATHERS DO.
IN THAT ONE FROZEN IMAGE, THERE
IT IS.
THAT'S WHAT WORK LOOKS LIKE AND
THAT'S WHAT DADS DO WHO WANT TO
BE THERE TO BE PRESENT FOR THEIR
KIDS.
THEY SHOW UP.
THEY DON'T WORRY ABOUT THE DRESS
CODE.
THEY JUST SHOW UP.
I THOUGHT IT WAS KINDS OF
AWESOME.
DAN: MIKE, I WILL PAY YOU A
COMPLIMENT AND I HOPE YOU TAKE
IT.
YOU HAVE BECOME THE FACE OF
WORKING AMERICA.
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND YOU ARE AN
ADVOCATE AND VOICE FOR THEM.
YOU ARE STARTING TO SEE A
POLITICAL SHIFT IN THIS COUNTRY.
SO MANY PEOPLE ENGAGE IN
IDENTITY POLITICS STUFF, PEOPLE
DON'T THINK OF THEMSELVES AS
HISPANIC OR BLACK.
THEY THINK OF THEMSELVES AS
AMERICANS.
SOMETIMES THEY JUST WANT TO BE
LEFT ALONE.
GO TO WORK, MAKE MY MONEY, GET A
DECENT EDUCATION AND LEAVE ME
THE HELL ALONE AND GET AWAY FROM
IDENTITY POLITICS STUFF.
>> LIVE A BALANCED LIFE.
I SEE TONIGHT MY FOUNDATION
EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
WE HELP PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
MASTER A SKILL THAT'S IN DEMAND.
PEOPLE WILLING TO GO WHERE THE
WORK IS.
TIME AND TIME AGAIN WE SEE HOW
THAT PAYS DIVIDENDS.
THANK YOU FOR THE COMPLIMENT.
I WILL TAKE IT.
I DON'T THINK PART OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THIS CONSTANT,
YOU KNOW, LEFT RIGHT, GOOD BAD,
RIGHT, WRONG BINARY CHOICES.
I THINK BLUE COLLAR AND WHITE
COLLAR ARE -- I DON'T THINK THE
COLOR OF COLLARS MATTERS AS MUCH
AS IT USED TO.
I ONLY SAY THAT BECAUSE I'M
OFTEN GUILTY MYSELF OF SAYING
THIS IS THE WHITE COLLAR WORLD
AND THE BLUE COLLAR WORLD.
BUT THE GUYS YOU DESCRIBED
PULLING THOSE TRUCKS AND THE GUY
IN THE COAL MINE, THE AMOUNT OF
TECHNOLOGY THEY DEAL WITH IS
INCREDIBLE.
THE AMOUNT OF RAW BRAIN POWER
THEY NEED TO SOLVE PROBLEMS AND
DO THEIR JOB, IT'S NOT STEREO
TYPICAL OF WHAT BLUE COLLAR USED
TO MEAN.
I THINK WE ARE COMING INTO AN
AGE WHERE PEOPLE WILL BE LESS
MINDFUL OF THE COLOR OF COLLARS
AND MORE INTERESTED IN THE DADS
WHO SHOW UP.
MORE INTERESTED IN THE WORKERS
WHO SHOW UP AND DO THE JOB,
WHATEVER THE JOB IS, SHOWING UP,
THAT'S WHAT'S FOR SALE RIGHT
NOW.
DAN: THAT'S A GREAT POINT, MIKE.
MIKE ROWE, THANKS FOR COMING ON.
YOU CAN CATCH THE LATEST S